we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
in any time here's a topic that has come
up before and i'm glad to have the
opportunity to address it again
take a listen hi david i'm a big fan of
the show my name is greg i was wondering
what you were thinking about a topic
involving restricting votes based on
civic knowledge and the requirement to
pass the citizenship test to vote and i
was thinkin that could glue in
coordination with something like voting
holiday so everyone would have time to
do this every year and you could take it
any number of times and pass but you
cannot vote unless you pass it with
flying colors give you your thoughts
thanks
so i understand the motivation here and
the motivation is that ignorant people
voting is a huge problem and we would
all be better off if there was some
minimum particular knowledge required in
order to vote but here's the problem
aside from whether it could even be done
constitutionally i have no confidence
that this would be implemented without
serious bias because as soon as you put
the idea of some kind of test to vote on
the table and again i don't think you
could even do it legally i don't think
it would be constitutional but imagine
that you could the lobbying groups would
immediately start to use their influence
to push the test to favor their side and
it would inevitably end up
disproportionately disenfranchising poor
people and minority voters and what
should happen is let's just educate
people and get more people to vote the
solution is not to end up with better
elected officials by blocking huge
portions of the population from voting
because they don't have the right
knowledge or can't pass a test that's
effectively what the right is doing with
voter suppression tactics when they say
let's make it more difficult for people
to vote let's require more documents for
people to vote let's limit the number of
places where people can vote that's
limit the number of
during which people can vote what you're
doing is you are trying to win by having
a smaller number of people participate
in the democratic process I'm not for
that okay so on the Left I get the
instinct of saying if smarter people
voted we would do way better and the
country would be way better off let's
start teaching civics and critical
thinking at an earlier age the right
doesn't want to do that because they
understand the implications let's do all
of the things that will increase turnout
because in the long run that's a much
better way they get a better functioning
democracy than by making it even more
difficult for people to vote
particularly particularly in ways that
will be enforced in a discriminatory
fashion I'm not for it and I've been
against it for a long time we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member become a patron I look forward to
speaking to you then we've got some
great stories to discuss and a lot more
coming up